salut à tous c'est pêcheurs de trésor
aujourd'hui nous sommes à Bordeaux où on
a trouvé un petit canal et on a envie de
savoir ce qui se cache sous l'eau ouais
première fois à Bordeaux on est en
compagnie de notre nouvelle stagiaire
Jade et de notre deuxième stagiaire
syidney qui est là avec rasta ils sont
tous les deux en haut et là j'ai déjà
quelque chose ah ben allez voyons voir
tout de suite ce que Canal nous
réserve h du câble non du câble non
ouais des morceaux d'acier bon ok
d'ord ah j'ai peut-être eu un truc au
milieu ouais mais c'est pas très lourd
on va
regarder ok juste un tube enin une
barre allez la stagiaère elle a une
belle trouvaille là je pense si si si si
ou ça buûle encore
ou là qu'est-ce que
c'est oh c'est un comment ça
s'appelle est tomber dans l'eau attends
j'ai un parf c'est pour ça que c'est ah
ouais d'accord ah oui bah belle
trouvaille j'en ai
chier pêcher un parpum pêcher l'iment
c'est une première ok super tu vois qu'
fait le taf ton petit aiment là bah
ouais regardez le terror de chez Maison
de la détection voilà si vous voulez
pêcher des parpins voilà belle
trouvaille sympa une belle
TR ok une clé oh j'ai une clé USB ça
peut être intéressant ça
selon ce qu'elle contient là regardez on
est sur un nouveau spot très sympa
toujours à Bordeaux et regardez ce qu' a
repéré rasta des tortues qui chill on va
essayer on va essayer de pas les assomer
avec les émars mais on va tirer loin de
toute façon vont partir ouais très sympa
en tout cas de voir ça surtout qu' elle
est bien
grosse et des canard et un ragondin
regardez la biodiversité ici c'est ouf
on a la
totale un beau petit Ragon j'espère que
c'est propre ici pour tous ces animaux
on va voir si c'est propre on va pas les
embêter bon ben là j'ai eu quelque chose
s cette passerelle ouais on a changé
d'endroit on est à l'endroit des tortues
et des ragondin c'est assez lourd ça
peut être du
vélo ah oui tu vois non oh non un tube
ah un gros tube ah c'est une borne de
signalis ah mais c'est super lourd tu
veux que t'aide
ouais je veux bien de
l'IDE
ah [__] tu es pas à
plat
att il est rempli d'eau c'est c'est pour
ça que c'est
lourd attention auent avec la barrière
ou ok euh
la bar on va se verser de l'auudessus en
plus si on le soulève comme ça non mais
pour juste on essaie de le verser
tu bascule pour qu'il se
verse regardez comment on galère juste
pour un plot ouais wop
avant ou l'arrière comme vous voulez par
le haut voilà tu le fais toi jade moi
j'attrape tant qu'on est pas de l'eau il
va pas ah ben voilà là il va être moins
lourd non ouais
allez nickel tac
chien voilà première trouvaille sur ce
nouveau spot bon ben on va continuer on
va voir ce qu'on trouve iciit du poid et
mais il est pas vieux hein par contre
hein
c'est tout propre ici de tout façon
c'est tout neuf deuxième trouvaille on
va voir ce que c'est ah c'est moins
lourd quo que peê pareil les gars ah
c'est pareil mais il est dans le bon
sens ah donc si ce vide là ça devrait le
faire B non c'est bon vu qu'il est vide
ça passe
seul et voilà tout
deè là ça bule là j'ai ramassé des
petits objets je crois enfin parce que
les les gros là non merci
ouais j'ai quelque chose c'est
intéressant en vrai j'aime le poids W un
antivol de
scooter oui
oui ça c'est quoi ah oui un dessus de
poteau aou j'ai failli perdre un doigt
c'est dangereux c'est dangereux c'est
dangereux j'ai eu vraiment de la chance
j'ai eu un peu mal mais ça va mais c'est
le dessus d'un autre non d'un autre d'un
troème
ok ouais faut le
trouver ah ça c'est le
poteau ah ah peêre un truc dans la vase
ici là je t quelque chose et ouais
regardez là quand on creuse un peu oui
oui ouais il est pas mal ce
spot premier abord on naurait pas dit
mais
ouais je l'ai hein c'est assez lourd
allez vélo vélo vélo on y croit
oui oui les enfants j'urais besoin
d'aide d'aide avec un aant ou tu veux
que j'essayer de rattraper B aide-moi
aide-moi ça va lâcher le mec il va
lâcher mon premier vélo de la journée
qui est peut-être électrique hein ouais
attends je venais à l'instant de jeter
mon un peu loin donc tu vas et ça
regardez ça vous voyez c'est le spot où
vraiment je savais qu'il allait avoir un
vélo je connais en plus il y avait des
gens un peu cuux qui nous demandait ce
qu'on faisait et quand a dit oui il y a
des vélos des fois ils étaient là mais
pourquoi il y aurait des
vélos comme quoi et ouais comme quoi on
dit n'importe quoi mais pas tout le
temps non non on arrive à prévoir quand
même un peu bon vasy je vais essayer de
le choper j'ai l'impression qu'il est
par là le reste ouais ah tu es bien là
non ouais ouais alle est nickel ou il
est pas très vieux il est électrique il
y a des câbles il des câbles ouais mais
pas très lourd c'est un vélo de la ville
ça
ouais on bascule allez nickel atttion
CNÉ oh oui attention au chien l'antivol
il y a le ok ah oui il y a l'antivol ici
il est même pas non mais c'est qu'il est
même pas
en sont pas si fatigué c'est quel marque
ça le bleu là c'est il pas vu les trucs
libre là ouais c'est truc libre ouais
ouais il est libre je sais pas quoi
sympa pour l'instant c'est moi qui a la
plus belle trouvaille bon allez on
continue ouais ah oui ils ont volé volé
un truc la batterie la batterie
peut-être ouais il quelque chose qui a
été volé
ouais allez une pièce c'est quoi 5
centimes 5 centimes d'euros ok n'empêche
que ça reste de l'argent je garde allez
va voir ce qu'on trouve dans ce point
d'eau en espérant ne pas assommer de
tortues si vous avez une idée en
commentaire je remre plein de
microobilles il y en a de différentes
tailles il y en a des un peu plus
grosses c'est le focus elles son Moné tu
vois Z bras de loin ouais ouais ouais
intéressant je sais pas trop on a jamais
vu ça un métal spécial peut-être ça fait
comme du plomb mais Moné on va aller sur
un nouveau spot donc là on est en plein
Bordeaux cette fois-ci un petit port
mais en attendant on a trouvé un endroit
avec plein de canette alors non est pas
amentée celle est pas amentée c'est la
poussière et on va ramasser toutes les
canettes qu'elles soient en alu ou pas
il faut savoir qu'une can une canette en
alu au prix du pois c'est environ 3
centimes ouais donc c'est pas mal il y
en a partout là a partout on va voir
comment on arrive à en prendre allez
c'est parti il y a du plastique aussi
mais vu qu'il y a pas de poubelle on
peut pas le ramasser maintenant nous on
va faire la partie
recyclage tout ce qu'on peut recycler là
il MTI TIG ça
puz le résultat minutes 5
minutes les par contre çaur est horrible
minut un compl 5 minutes et encore on
pas pas mal pas mal moi je dirais 1 €
peut-être plus c'est que l' lu ouais
peut-être plus 3 centimes unité donc tu
en a 10 ça fait 30 centimes ouais une
trentaine ça fait 1 € que j'ai trouvé
aussi PC ah non
Xbox Xbox ouais c'est une xbox ouais
mais non voilà une xbox à
[Musique]
vendre
ouais enfin quelque
chose juste un
tournevis si si j'ai eu un tournevis
presque comme neuf la corde tant pis
pour elle ouais c'est pas mal c'est la
meilleure trouvaille de
l'endroit ah ouais mais c'est le bord
ça dommage j'arrive pas à m'empêcher de
m'accrocher au bord il y a la poli
allez vienez là bonjour bonjour oui ils
sont gentils oui j'en fait aussi de l'
ouais mais c'est propre ici il y a
beaucoup de pêcheurs non ouais bah je
pense tout on a essayé le là là rien
rien que non que c'est propre vous
connaissez notre chaîne on est sur
Youtube fait chir de trésor c'est vrai
ouais ah ok ouais fait partout en France
bah même en Europe on a fait Berlin
Amsterdam et alors les trouvailles des
de tout ouais ouais ben Berlin on a fait
MP40 en plein centre ouais de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale il était en quel état
pourri ouais il était pourri ouais mais
bon ça reste il garde la forme quoi
forme plus cétait en [__] pas en bois
donc ah ouais ouais ouais c'est possible
arrê par la police la après ils sont
venus pour il y avait des bombes
aussiouis ça fallait s'y attendre ouais
oua ah mais c'est bien cool et ben ti je
je vais prendre en photo avec vous
parce mon gamin il doit vous
connaîtrere à côté de je recule encore
un MRE ou pas
on va tester un peu en direct
ou
garveem sont sur YouTube a il vient de
nuit avec un bateau vient plonger dans
les G du coin il on pas dro
lque
marine
sympa bon vous voulez pêcher allément
ici mais il y a trop d'algues du coup on
a vu qu'il y avait un concert on va y
aller comme ça ça fait un peu punk à
chien mais bon ouais c'est bizarre je
sais pas les gens ils nous regardent
bizarrement ils sont tous bien habillés
mais je pense que ça passe hein on va
profiter de la ville de
Bordeaux à la semaine prochaine pour une
nouvelle vidéo de pêche
àém un couple mixte mais trop mignon oui
alors oui je me suis dououchée à priori
quand même hein non il bien les filles
non c'est machine en chaleur alors en ce
moment il est un peu tout le monde il en
chaleur arrête
écoute le nous